we don't have to like our jobs every day
but we do get to love our jobs every
days like you don't like your children
every day but you love your children
every day so having a this a hard day
you know that that's fine but the
question is is what do we fall in love
with and at the end of the day the
reason
um uh that we Stay or Leave a job is
because how we feel about that job you
know I think we we misunderstand when we
think people just leave for money if
they just leave for money then they
never really had strong feelings of the
company in the first place right because
when people feel loyal to the company
they turn down jobs that offer them more
money or if it's so tempting and the
numbers are so high then they go to
their company and say listen I was
offered this job it's very tempting
there's a lot of pressure but I don't
want to lead is there anything you can
do to help me stay right so and you and
there's the point is is there they're
open about it and and what makes people
want to have that conversation like I
said is that they're seen and heard
um the best companies
um have all kinds of programs inside the
company to help the person grow as an
individual now we talked about you know
listening skills and these kinds of
things these are valuable for the work
that we do but it turns out that those
skills also help us as parents they help
us as as as spouses or as boyfriends and
his girlfriends these are valuable
skills in life
you know
um and I think that we forget that we
talk about hard skills and soft skills
as if those things are opposite it's a
terror I hate the term soft skills hard
skills and human skills and the more
that we invest in human skills in
addition to the hard skills that we're
teaching the more people feel like
they're growing as individuals I'm a
better version of myself now than I was
when I started at this company because
the company is actually helping me on a
in personal growth
um uh WD-40 which is a company that I
admire their their culture uh the
lubricant company
um uh they train their managers to be
coaches so literally like Executive
coaching training that kind of thing but
they train their own people to do to
have that skill set so that they're
equipped to help their people who have
challenges and especially with younger
generation you know the younger
generation is asking companies to
provide everything you know we want to
have our sense of belonging our sense of
community our sense of personal growth
our sense of purpose to come from where
work it didn't used to be like that 40
years ago and so and so there's a huge
pressure on companies and so I think
what entices people into the company and
into the industry is not just come and
do cyber security you know there's a
percentage of people who are you know de
facto interested in that but rather tell
them the kind of experience they're
going to have tell them what they get
from the company and you'll find it
remarkable how many people will all of a
sudden be interested in the in the
category in the company because of what
they get holistically not just what they
get from the product we have to remember
what what gets measured gets done we
have to remember that the you you know
it's I hear this all the time you know
companies talk about we we want our
people we encourage our people to be
Innovative and we encourage our people
to look at problems differently and try
new things but when you look at the
recognition and reward programs and
structures they only get uh recognized
reward or incent or incentivized based
on hitting Financial targets and so for
all the talk of what we want our people
to do if there's no form recognition or
Rewards program that recognizes and
rewards the behaviors then you're only
going to get the ones that are rewarded
um uh uh and so like I said the best
companies have a little more holistic
approach it's totally fine to recognize
and reward for performance but it needs
to be balanced with some other
attributes as well